hey guys so today we're introducing a
new Spotify experience the new Spotify
has been built to deliver new types of
content including non music content to
deepen our users engagement with Spotify
what a perfect marriage to put audio
content on one of the best audio
platforms in the world Spotify in the
pursuit of making video content and I
know that Spotify is jumping into this
world and the audience that you guys
have it's the perfect thing to do we are
thrilled to be here on the launch date
for the new Spotify platform you know we
want to watch those Clips we are the
demo we love the demo we're talking
about our clips and how they're gonna
slide right in there you know the short
clips that people can watch in the
middle of the day your phone already has
sensors built in the can to take how you
move
Spotify can take that information figure
out your pace and find that track that
magically matches the beat of your feet
even between songs there's an incredible
opportunity to soundtrack your entire
day and in your entire life in all of
its complexity and we're just taking a
huge leap ahead to give it to you